foreign
e joins us up next in Orlando Florida
Renee welcome to the show
hi thank you
um
so just a little bit of backstory my
husband and I were in our mid-30s and we
both work for for in front line
positions at one of the major theme
parks in the area and we also have a
six-year-old son and for the last three
months we've been living in a hotel
because we could no longer afford our
rent in our apartment and financially we
are just not in a place to buy a house
um we've
been able to secure an apartment but the
real issue is
um we ended up falling for
um as you would say George the stupid
tax of
um getting into payday loans and
installment loans and now we're like
twenty five thousand dollars in debt and
we make like 75 000 a year but between
the weekly payments on those loans and
our regular bills were suffocating under
um under our debt and we don't know how
to get out of it
um we were just turned on to your show
um the Ramsey Solutions maybe like a
couple days ago from a co-worker of mine
and we've found Hope in it so far but
we've been hearing stuff on the show
like baby steps and emergency funding we
don't know what any of that stuff is and
we just we don't know how to start we
don't know where to go from here we
don't have anything in savings we don't
have anything for retirement we don't
have anything for our kids and we would
like to have more children someday and
set up a stable future and a stable home
life for them eventually
so I'm so sorry to hear all about this
for now
gosh are you ready
yes
like when George starts talking here
like you have to say you're ready and
what that means is you're ready to quit
your jobs if you have to you're ready to
move out of the area if you have to
you're ready to change everything are
you in
yes we're ready Steve my husband and I
we've already started looking into
um
schooling to
um get different jobs
um you know stay in the jobs that we
have right now so that we can fund the
schooling that we're going to because um
the company we're at they will fund
higher education for free
um and my husband he currently has a
bachelor's in psychology and wants to go
to school for a master's of Social Work
to be a guidance counselor and I'm
looking into real estate school because
I don't have any desire to go to college
per se and throw money into a system
where there's no guarantee of me getting
a job in that field so okay so you're
ready so George is going to walk you
through it yeah so I love that you guys
want to further your education and get
out of this hole but right now we're in
survival mode and so I'm not thinking
about school I'm thinking about how are
we going to put food on the table and
stop living in hotels and make sure our
six-year-old is taken care of
and so A1 is to stop going into debt are
you guys done there are you still having
to take out these payday loans to get by
no we're we're done we
we did take out some credit cards a
couple of months ago but we have since
stopped using them and um can you
physically cut them up
yes cut them up and throw them away so
you don't know the numbers anymore
okay and then we're going to pay those
off completely and we're going to close
all of those accounts
and we're not going to look at credit
card companies and payday loans as a
blessing to get us through next week
they are snakes
okay they prey on people in your
situation okay who are working their
butts off to try to make it work and
want the best for their little kid and
just can't make the ends meet they prey
on you
they give me and George they give us
free flights and you pay for them
okay
they are not your friend
so once we're saying no to debt let me
ask the interest on these payday loans
because I think it's going to make us
all throw up
oh
too much to
yeah is it in the hundreds
I probably I mean we're we're spending
twelve hundred dollars a month on these
payday loans what other debt do you have
um we both have car payments um and I've
looked into selling them off and we are
basically upside down on both of our
cars because again it was a buy here pay
here kind of place so astronomical
interest rates okay what other you have
two car loans you get the payday loans
you have the credit cards what else
um the credit cards were actually not in
debt on
um we we make those payments zero
balance okay we just stopped using them
um but we also have like medical bills
and collections I have maybe twelve
hundred dollars in medical bills and
Collections and my husband has
1400 in collection okay so what we're
going to do is A1 is we're not going
into more debt that's baby Step Zero
we're gonna stop the bleeding your next
step is to scrape together a thousand
dollars as quickly as possible that's a
that's going to go into a savings
account I know that sounds like how are
we going to do that we have no margin
and this is where we go obviously you
guys aren't living lavishly
all of your money is going to death
lavishly in a long time so right now
you're expensive haircut in a year your
expenses are your four walls is what I'm
guessing food utilities housing
transportation
and then anything my kid needs okay
this might mean that we are working 60
70 hour weeks and we're trading spots to
take care of the six-year-old for a few
weeks just so we can get out from being
underwater let's tell her what that like
that means he your husband gets off of
work and he doesn't come home
yeah that's what we've been doing my
husband's been doing double shifts good
six six or seven days a week because he
can my my role at this theme park um
they don't allow overtime but have you
talked to your employer your leaders
there and explain what's going on
yeah and
could they put you up in some of their
housing on the property temporarily they
don't they don't have it I mean they
have it for the college kids but do you
have somebody actual do you have
somebody who could
um
watch your kid for you
we we will now
um because like our closest family is
three hours away
um in a complex that's an hour away from
work but we actually have friends that
live in the complex that would be
willing to so it might be for 30 days
from time to time well it might be for
30 days you ask them tell them hey we're
in a mess and the moment you get off
you're going straight to drive Uber or
deliver ubereats or deliver instacart
and all we're trying to do is get a
thousand dollars get a thousand dollars
you're gonna get a thousand dollars in
your account and you're gonna take a
deep breath for the first time in a long
time
okay
and you're gonna do whatever it takes
even if it's I'm staying with friends
I'm gonna get plugged into a local
church and do whatever you can to get
there baby step two is listing all the
debts smallest to largest regardless of
the interest rate and attacking it with
a Vengeance with all the margin you can
muster up with all the income you can
create with all the expenses you can
shave down and it might be hard at first
but when you knock out that first debt
you are going to be on cloud nine and
you're gonna feel like oh my gosh we can
do this thing
and You're Gonna Knock Out The Next Step
The Next Step what does that do it frees
up the payments on those now giving you
a bigger snowball to keep rolling and
that's called the debt snowball method
okay and once you do that over the next
you know it may What's the total amount
of debt you guys have
um I would say between 25 and 30 000 you
guys can do this easy you make 75k you
got 25 to pay off we've heard much
smaller incomes with much bigger numbers
and they were able to do it so I want
you the key to all of this is just
believing that you can do it and we're
going to help you and walk with you by
giving you one year Financial Peace
University watch all nine lessons with
your husband and to get fired up to give
you knowledge to give you motivation
we're going to give you one year of
every dollar premium to get on a written
plan a budget every single week you're
tracking every expense making every
dollar stretch as far as it can go
and I want you to call us back when
you're debt free and share your story
because it's going to give so many other
people out there hope who didn't think
it was possible for them